All right, let's see here. Skye's back.
How you doing, Sky? Hello. Um, I want
your good reason for why Islam is why
why Islam is true or why should anybody
accept Islam. So, you just want that?
Yes. So, this is I kind of like a
personal reason and not really an
objective one, but it's my opinion. I
want something objective. Objective. I
mean, this is objective. I mean, you
have to listen to it to understand. So
basically I when I was like really young
I've looked at a lot of religions before
Islam. The thing is when I looked on
those religions they were really
complicated with different doctrines.
But what I found in Islam was it was one
concrete answer of one God being all
powerful and not a triune God or other
systems. That's what I can say. So,
you're saying because Allah has a
simpler concept of God, therefore it's
true above the other concepts of God.
Yeah. The reason for that is even a
5-year-old can understand it. Really? I
mean, yeah. God is one and that's your
God. He's one what? What do you mean
when you say God is one? One what?
One God. God is one person. One person.
Does the Quran say that? That's what I
would say. Does the Quran say that? Yes,
it does. It's on every word. Say your
God is one. Yeah. Show me show me where
it says he's one person. Cuz you said
when you say one one person. Let me see.
One person. Remember this is supposed to
be simple. Even a child can get this
right. So it should be right right
there. So do not argue with the people
of the book unless gracefully except
with those of them who act wrongfully
and say we believe in what has been
revealed to us and what has been
revealed to you or God. And your God is
only one. And him only way.
Only one God. Your God is only Your God
is only one. Like for example, if I were
to say, uh, Sky, you're only one. Do you
know what I'm talking about when I say
that you're only one? Uh, I'm one
person. That's what I would How do you
know that I'm talking about person? How
do you know I'm not just talking about
humans? Or, uh, how do you know I'm not
just talking about Muslim that's on my
panel right now? I would understand that
because you just said you're one. No,
you wouldn't. You cannot conclude that
I'm only that I'm talking about one
person. How does that make sense?
Because there's other things that you're
you're one of, right? Like you could be
the one you could be one Muslim that's
here on my panel. You could be one human
being that I'm talking to. You could be
you know what I'm saying? So when I say
sky you're one that's not tell one what?
You get what I'm saying? So when it says
that Allah is one one what? You say one
verse also doesn't say that. Um the
verse I quoted is alab 46 and it says
your god is only one. One what? It is
one only. Nice one and only. Only one
what? God. It doesn't say that. How so?
It just says only one. It doesn't tell
you one what. So So let's so let's go
with this. So if he's one God, that
doesn't negate that he's multiple
persons within one God, right? I mean,
multiple persons cannot be in one
person. I I I agree that multiple person
cannot be in one person. That would be a
contradiction. But multiple persons can
be in one god though, one being. So how
do you know when it says he's when
you're taking it to mean one God that
it's only one person? Because the word
says it. Our god your go and your god is
only I'll ask I'll ask it again. I'll
ask it again. Scott and I need you to
follow along if this is going to last.
Can you follow? You listening? Yeah, I
am. Okay, here we go. One what? Hold up.
I found a verse that says it's only God,
but not like the person. Hold up. That's
good. So, one God, right? Yeah. Okay. So
being one God doesn't negate that he's
one God who is multi-personal, right?
Oh, could you repeat that? My bad. Being
one God doesn't negate being
multi-personal, right? Multi-personal as
in what? I mean, meaning multiple
people, multiple persons, multiple
persons having the same divine nature as
the one God. Are you talking about them
having the same nature? Hey, Sky, you
you're you're pro you're not ready for
this, brother. I'm sorry. And so I don't
think that this will be it wouldn't be
fair for me to continue this
conversation. You're you're just you're
not ready to have this conversation,
bro. So I'mma politely move on to the
next person. Okay. Wait, wait a second.
Wait, wait a second. What should I wait
on? Are you about to enlighten me
somehow? Are you about to, you know,
grow in knowledge in the span of two
seconds right now and and wisdom?
I
actually this was something that just
came up to my mind also the wife beating
words that
I can supposed to be so this is supposed
to be so simple but yet you cannot
explain to me the concept of your god
but it's so simple a 5-year-old can my
concept of my god is he is only one all
right thank you take care the man the
myth the legend how you doing good good
what about you pretty good you're a
Muslim mhm awesome So, so, so you're
asking uh why should you accept Islam,
right? Yes. Because it is the only
monotheistic religion that gives a
ration a logically rational description
of one God. A logically rational
description of one God. Okay. It's the
only monotheistic religion that gives a
that gives a a logically rational
description of God. Of one god. Okay. Is
Allah spiritual? Is he a spirit or is he
physical? What exactly do you mean? I'm
asking what is Allah basically? Is he a
Is he a spirit? Is he a physical being?
Uh he he's God. That's all he is. I I I
hear that claim. But what is he though?
Like what is his That's what I'm trying
to tell you. We say there is nothing
like unto God. We don't say God is a
spirit. We don't say that he's physical.
We say that God is God. So he's nothing.
Nothing like God. No, he's something. He
is God. Is he Is he immaterial or
material? Well, like I said, we don't
say that. We say if he's not immaterial,
brother, if he's not immaterial or
material, then he's nothing. He doesn't
exist. He has to be one or the other. So
already with these basic questions, you
don't have a coherent concept of the one
God. You're saying that you're basically
telling me he doesn't exist. No, he
exists just not in in categories. He he
exists as what? As God. Is he material?
Does he have a material existence or an
immaterial existence? He does not have a
material existence. So, he has an
immaterial existence. I I don't know if
I I mean I I would just say that he
doesn't have a material existence, which
would mean that he has an immaterial
existence, right? I guess you could put
it that way. Okay. Are there other
things in creation that have immaterial
existence? Uh, no. No, not entirely. Do
angels have a material existence or an
immaterial existence? Uh, they're
material. You can see them. You can see
them. Yeah. What about when you can't
see them? What do you mean you could see
angels right now? No. But if an angel
were to come and reveal himself to me, I
would see him. Can a can an angel be in
the room with you right now and be
invisible? Uh, if God permits it, but
that wouldn't change his form. So,
you're saying that angels naturally have
a visible form? Yes. Do they have a form
like a man or what's what's their form
like? Are they able to come in different
forms? We don't know. This is not stuff
that's revealed to us. We know that
there that uh when the angel appeared to
the prophet it's clear that many people
attested to the fact that they saw the
angel appeared to the prophet. So it's
clear that when angels appear the
prophets they appear in visible form.
Now all the other questions you're
asking what for what forms they appear
in all this stuff it's not revealed to
us at least not from my knowledge. Okay.
What about Allah? What what form does he
appear in? We don't know. We can't see
Allah. Does he have hands?
Uh he's he's described as having hands.
Does he have a shin? Yes. Does he have a
face and eyes? Uh I'm not sure on that
one. He does. He does. Yeah. So he has
hands, he has a shin, he has face, and
he has eyes.
And he's unlike anything in his in his
creation. Mhm. Because we don't say that
our hands are like Allah's hands. We
don't say that our shins are like
Allah's shins. But he has hands
nonetheless. Right. He has hands like us
nonetheless. Not they are not like any
hands that any of creation no worries
but like his creation he has hands
right? No his hands are not alike to the
hands of his creation my brother no you
asked me if he has hands like his
creation. Do you know let me let me
clarify let me clarify. Okay creation
has hands right. There are things in
creation that has hands and Allah has
hands. Proper grammar have hands proper
grammar. Yes. All right. Thank you. So
there are things that are in creation
that have hands and then Allah also has
hands, right? So therefore there is a
similarity with Allah and creation in in
that both possess hands. Correct? No.
Because like like I said, the hands of
creation are not like the hands of
Allah. So they don't have a similarity.
It's just are the hands are the hands of
a koala bear like the hands of a human?
Yes. You have they are you have
vertebrae within your hand. What What
about What about a clock? In fact, I got
you. What What about a clock? Does a Are
the hands of a clock hands? They're not
actual hands. That's metaphorical. What
are they called? They're called hands,
but they're not actual hands. That's
metaphorical. That's not even No, they
are actual hands. They're just the hands
of a clock. No, that's metaphorical,
dude. It's not Koala A koala bear's
hands a koala bear's hands and this the
exact same as a human's hands. No, but
they are alike in what manner in the
like the bone structure and things of
that nature? But they're not exactly
alike. No, but they are. So a koala bear
has different hands than a human does in
some aspects. Yes. And Allah has
different hands than a human does. In
all aspects, yes. In all aspects. In all
aspects. Then it's then it's not a hand
then, is it? No, it is a hand. It's just
a hand that is not akin to ours. It's
not hard. So then that means so Allah
has a hand. I have a hand. So me and
Allah are alike in that we both have a
hand. Correct. No, because nothing with
your hand compares to his hand. It's not
hard to understand. You just you you you
started off telling me that Islam has
the most logical and coherent concept of
the one God and right now you sound
Well, first off, what I meant
by concept is that we say one God. You
say one God and three persons, which is
incredibly You say one God and one
person. Yeah, that's completely logical.
It's completely logical to say one God
and three person. No, it's not. It's
it's completely logical to say one God
and three persons. When you say when you
when you talk about the concept of your
one God, sorry, excuse me. When you talk
about the concept of your one God, it's
not simply just that he's one God, but
it's what you what the concept of that
one God is. like he has hands and a
shin, face and eyes, ears, all of these
body parts, but that you say are not
hands and shin and feet or like it's
it's you. It's stupid. It's it's so
incoherent. Either we are alike either
he has hands and so therefore we are
alike in that we have hands or he we're
not alike at all. So he doesn't have
hands at all. Then that's not the worst.
And yes, the trinity is illogical cuz it
breaks the law of identity. What's the
law of identity? That a is a that a
cannot not be a. What law? For example,
the Titanic, right? You familiar with
the Titanic? Yes. Okay. The Titanic,
when it was built and finished, it was
fresh and beautiful, big. It looked
unbreakable, right? No scratches, no
scars, no dents, right? Not entirely
true, but yeah. When it left the island
and crashed into the iceberg and broke
and sunk, it now had new scratches and
dents and holes, right? Is it is it the
same identical Titanic ship that left
the island? Yes. But wait a second. It's
has new scratches and it has it's broken
and it's not in the same shape that it
that it left in. Doesn't matter. It's
still the same Got it. So it
doesn't have to be absolutely identical
in every way for it to be identical,
right? It can be relatively identical.
Correct? Uh to itself. Yes. And only to
itself. Nice. So saying that God is
three persons does not break the law of
identity because the persons are
identical in their essence while they
are distinct in their personhood. That
is called relative identity. So they're
identical in one way while they're
distinct in another. Did you answer? I
said to how does this how does this
solve how does this solve your
incoherency with Allah having hands but
not but not but not having hands or not
being like his creation but uh but he
has hands just like me, legs just like
me and eyes just like me. Can I please
answer? So first you didn't understand
the answer that I gave you. I said yes,
there can be uh they can have some
similarities if it's talking if it's in
the same thing. Meaning the Titanic is
identical to the Titanic. If it's still
the Titanic Apple here is different from
an apple
there. Simple as
that. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Simple as that.
Sorry. Do me a favor, man. Watch your
head on the way out. Don't hit it. Don't
hit it. Don't hit your head on the way
out. Sorry about that. I just wanted to
warn you first, watch your head on the
way out. Even though if you bumped it,
it wouldn't do anything. It wouldn't do
damage. Ain't a ain't nothing in there
to damage. But still, just, you know, as
a requirement for the live stream, I'm
required to give you the warning to
watch your head even though there ain't
nothing in